et avec nous pour en parler david
rigoulet roze rédacteur en chef de la
revue orient stratégique vous est aussi
chercheur à l'institut français
d'analysé stratégique spécialiste du
moyen-orient merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés gerald de olivier chercheur
associé à l'ipp ce spécialiste des états
unis votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule
sur la route de la maison blanche aux
éditions picollec bonsoir également
avons gérald olivier tout d'abord ce
soir le cabinet de sécurité israélien
qui se réunit pour discuter d'un
possible cessez-le-feu avec le hamas
vous y croyez david rigoulet roze à ce
cessez-le-feu
on va vers un cessez-le-feu la question
c'est à quel moment puisque le la
question c'est le moment opportun entre
guillemets par rapport aux opérations
militaires
d'autres salles qui sont engagés jeu par
rapport à effectivement où est donc la
question
la remise aller en question simplement
effectivement il s'agit d'affaiblir
durablement
l'organisation qui a bénéficié
justement depuis 2014 deux possibilités
de reconstitution de ses stocks de
roquettes et on a vu un certaine
certains lancements qui essayait de
saturer le justement la protection
d'israël
le bouclier des rames l'iron dôme et
c'est c'était une objets qui s'était
aussi démonstration des capacités
opérationnelles du ramasse en plus de la
dimension politique qui était le fait de
présenter d'une certaine manière la
cause palestinienne et là on retrouve
aussi les enjeux de hadera palestine par
rapport à main
qui est qui est très marginalisés dans
cette affaire david rigaud les roses
viennent nous parler justement de ces
objectifs qu'il fallait atteindre gérald
olivier pour les palestiniens
pardon pour les israéliens pas confondre
c'est pas le moment effectivement c'est
pour cela d'ailleurs que benyamin
nétanyahou n'a pas écouté un joe biden
lui demandait la désescalade et un un
cessez-le-feu il fallait poursuivre à
tout prix ses derniers objectifs pour
benyamin nétanyahou écouter dans cette
affaire israël se trouve en état de
légitime défense
et quand on connaît la façon dont israël
gère les conflits à ses frontières avec
gaza notamment comme elle l'a fait au
cours des décennies un petit problème de
son ami de rigoler rose je vais vous
faire prendre le relais ce qu'on vous
êtes toujours avec nous gérald olivier
oui voilà vous êtes revenu pardonnez
nous on vous a perdu quelques secondes
on va vous vous laisser reprendre votre
propos oui nous excuser non je disais
simplement que 10
israël dans cette affaire est en état de
légitime défense et qu'elle va mener ses
opérations jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire
pour aider vite pour afin d'éviter qu'à
l'avenir elle soit à nouveau la cible de
ce type de tirs de roquettes
et on connaît très bien comment
fonctionne benjamines netanyahu
tant que ça ne sera pas sûr d'avoir
atteint ses objectifs
eh bien il trouvera un prétexte pour
repousser de cessez le feu
maintenant comme le disait david ya
quelques minutes le cessez-le-feu
la question c'est on peut très bien
interrompre les tirs pendant quelques
heures voir pendant quelques jours mais
ce qu'il va être durable c'est la
première question
et puis la deuxième question c'est
qu'est ce qui se passe au delà du
cessez-le-feu
parce qu'en l'occurrence c'est le hamas
qui a attaqué israël
c'est le hamas qui gère gaza et l'on
sait parfaitement que le hamas n'a
jamais été intéressé par la paix
à partir de là il devient très très
difficile de gérer les opérations il
devient difficile même pour les états
unis même pour le premier allié d'israël
d'être suffisamment convaincant pour
demander à benjamin netanyahu de faire
un cessez le feu avant qu'il ait atteint
ses objectifs
donc le cessez le feu viendra mais il
viendra qu'on les israéliens seront
prêts à ce qu'il entre en vigueur
david rigoulet vous devez vous faire
réagir dans quelques instants mais avoue
long stage voulez vous faire écouter ce
sont du ministre des affaires étrangères
allemand heiko maas écoute et nous
voyons aussi que l' escalade actuelles
alimentent la souffrance des gens des
deux côtés
le nombre de victimes augmente chaque
jour ce qui nous préoccupe beaucoup
c'est pourquoi nous soutenons les
efforts internationaux visant à
instaurer un cessez le feu et nous
sommes également convaincus que la
violence doit cesser rapidement dans
l'intérêt de la population
permettez moi de le redire très
clairement pour nous la sécurité
d'israël et avec elle la sécurité de
tous les juifs d'allemagne n'est pas
négociable et israël peut toujours
compter là dessus
david rigaud l'eros c'est surprenant
qu'on vous cette prise de position assez
ferme de la part de l'allemagne
heiko maas qui par ailleurs se trouvent
sur place et qui appelle à des contacts
indirects avec le hamas
non c'est pas surprenant s'il ya peu la
position allemande
d'ailleurs on peut noter que en termes
militaires les allemands fournissent des
des sous-marins israël compte tenu d'une
certaine histoire tragique
évidemment la position allemand nous
peut être que que sur la ligne 2 de
légitime défense de d'israël revendiqué
même si évidemment l'allemagne déplore
la situation dans son ensemble et là on
voit qu'au niveau européen n'a exercé le
problème il n'y a pas de bois unis on a
vu qu'il y avait des départs asie dans
une
commune qui était alimentée notamment
par la hongrie et donc c'est
effectivement préoccupant par rapport à
une position commune européenne même si
la position allemande est tout à fait
cohérente par rapport à ce qu'elle est
et ce qu'elle a toujours été en la
matière et elle n'est pas d'ailleurs
forcément contradictoire avec la
proposition française à l'onu l'objectif
étant de parvenir effectivement une
diminution de la confiture alité mais
pas au prix de la sécurité d'israël
alors c'est vrai que ça a le mérite en
tout cas d'être clair c'est un tout
petit peu moins clair de la part de l'ue
et des états unis les états unis qui
appelle un cessez-le-feu ont directement
auprès du ministre israélien du premier
ministre mais qui ne veulent pas de
cette résolution
gérald olivier pour quelles raisons
cette prudence je ne sais pas comment
l'appeler des états unis écoutez les
etats-unis ont toujours défendu israël
devant l'onu notamment au sein du
conseil de sécurité
vous pouvez remonter jusqu'à 50 ans en
arrière il n'ya pas s'il ya puis il n'y
a pas une seule résolution du conseil de
sécurité concernant israël qui n'est pas
reçu un veto américain si celles-ci
condamne est la politique d'israël la
seule exception
c'est une abstention qui était venu de
la part de l'administration obama fin
2016 mais c'est la seule je dirais
incartade à la règle qui veut que les
états unis soutiennent systématiquement
israël lorsque une organisation
internationale dont on sait que la
majorité des membres sont ouvertement
hostiles à israël ce qui est le cas de
l'organisation des nations unies
notamment de l'assemblée des nations
unies de l'assemblée générale eh bien
les etats-unis ont toujours été derrière
israël et ils le seront encore cette
fois cependant l'administration byden
aujourd'hui mois de voukoum et on a
entendu des démocrates pardonnez-moi
mais pousse mais dans l'autre sens un
bernie sanders elizabeth warren
on sent un autre une autre voie
aujourd'hui aux états unis
j'allais y venir
j'allais y venir dans la deuxième partie
de ma réponse il ya deux éléments à
prendre en considération aujourd'hui
c'est en effet que le parti démocrate
est au pouvoir et qu'il est soutenu par
son aile gauche et que son aile gauche
est à la fois très radicale et qu'elle
est devenue beaucoup plus vocal
récemment on l'a bien vu avant-hier
lorsqu'il y a eu un bref entretien sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport de détroit entre
la représentante du michigan qui est une
palestinienne américaine
madame plat yves et le président byden
la gauche américaine
aujourd'hui ce sont plus forte qu'elle
n'a jamais été et à partir de là elle se
sent en mesure d'imposer certaines
demandent au président bart hayden
maintenant vous avez une tradition au
département d'état et je ne pense pas je
ne pense pas très sincèrement que le
président soit prêt aujourd'hui à aller
contre cette tradition
donc je ne c'est la raison pour laquelle
pour l'instant les états unis s'opposent
à la résolution française au sein du
conseil de sécurité mais il n'empêche
que c'est des vikes et démocrates
peuvent mettre dans l'embarras peut-être
un président voilà qui ne sait pas sur
quel pied danser la vie de rigoler rose
la position des états unis a toujours
été clair on le sait dans ce conflit
israélo palestinien ciel devait plus ou
moins déserté un petit peu ce poste par
excès de prudence est ce que d'autres
pays pourraient prendre le lead
justement dans ces négociations c'est
déjà le cas d'ailleurs
oui mais en réalité rien ne se fera de
toute façon son sens en aval américains
comme me le rappelait géant l'olivier
c'est qu'effectivement c'est du fait du
soutien traditionnels inquiets qui est
apporté à l'onu asha que chaque
présentation de résolution et puis il ya
des velléités à ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'à l'onu il ya une
stigmatisation de la position américaine
par la chine qui est aujourd'hui qui
dirige le conseil qui préside le conseil
de sécurité en ce moment c'est assez
cocasse par rapport à 2
si tu as tu pris effectivement ou les
châles position des américains si
d'aventuré une résolution était présenté
à propos de la minorité chinoise même
chose pour les russes puisqu'ils ont
aligné les vétos pour dans la situation
syrienne donc en réalité la communauté
internationale c'est pas une entité en
tant que tel c'est un vaste forum
c'est par des intérêts politiques aux
politiques parfois convergents mais le
plus souvent divergents et et la
circulation conscience actuelle le
montre 'j'aurais géant olivier c'est la
fin de la lune de miel entre la france
et joe biden à l'occasion justement de
cette volonté de résolution de la part
de de paris que ne souhaite pas les
états unis qui bloque fin de de l'état
de grâce c'est un premier bras de fer on
va dire et la france essaye de se faire
entendre
maintenant vous savez dans cette affaire
il faut quand même le souligner
puisqu'on est à paris vous avez montré
l'interview du ministre des affaires
étrangères allemand qui a évoqué la
question des juifs d'israël mais
également des juifs en allemagne
la france est le pays d'europe avec la
plus importante minorité juif est le
pays d'europe avec la plus importante
minorité musulmane
le hamas est un mouvement qui est lié
aux frères musulmans
et donc il y a de la part de nos
dirigeants une crainte évidente d'une
forme d'externalisation d'exportation du
conflit on a bien vu la semaine dernière
que la manifestation pro palestinienne
qui a été prévu a été interdite par la
préfecture de police
et je crois qu'il ya un vrai souci de la
part de nos dirigeants de voir le
conflit dégénéré non pas sur place mais
s'étendre ici et prendre ici une autre
dimension qui ne s'est pas simplement
anti israéliennes mais qui deviendrait
antisémite
et c'est à partir de là que emmanuel
macron essaie de défendre une position
qui met un terme aux affrontements à
gaza le plus tôt possible pour permettre
de calmer la situation également ici
même david rigoulet roze
effectivement d'accord avec cette
analyse de gérald olivier les dirigeants
qui prennent évidemment position sur ce
conflit en fonction aussi de la réalité
intérieure
ah oui il ya une sensibilité très
particulière effectivement on comprend
bien et donc bon cela dit c'est conforme
à la position princes princesses de
principe mais mais il a
incontestablement une inquiétude qui qui
est sous jacente qui peut expliquer
effectivement la prison natif de prise
en cours de sa justement un pays qui
soutient comme les états unis envers et
contre tous donc les états israël et
c'est vrai que ces positions très très
compliqué pour le gouvernement français
parce que par ailleurs il n'est pas
question de rester d'état d'israël et
donc on voit bien que c'est une ligne de
fait qui est qui est très difficile à
gérer
ce qui explique probablement les
velléités effectivement de résolutions à
l'onu
même si sur le fond il n'y a pas
forcément d'antagonisme avait réouvert
avec avec l'administration parce que
aujourd'hui il ya une grande convergence
de vues qui s'est dessiné depuis la fin
du mandat de donald trump et notamment
sur un dossier central clip dossier du
nucléaire où il ya une vraie convergence
de vues pour le coup entre les deux
rives de l'atlantique
on l'a senti ces derniers mois et pas
seulement là dessus d'ailleurs y compris
par rapport à la question jus de la
chine du défi stratégique chinois donc
il ya une évolution mais simplement
effectivement là l'europe en général et
la france en particulier sont pas très à
l'aise dans le contexte actuel compte
tenu des enjeux que ça peut avoir en
termes de politique intérieure merci
beaucoup à tous les deux david rigoulet
roze uhalde olivier d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir